bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi
les corps des deux fillettes disparues
en belgique ont été retrouvés près d'une
voie ferrée les premiers constats
indique qu'elle aurait été assassiné peu
de temps après l'enlèvement un suspect
est toujours détenu lord man fait en
france après la qualification en quarts
de finale les joueurs se détendent
certains ont rencontré leurs familles
raymond domenech parle du plus beau
moment de sa carrière et dix mille
personnes ont fêté la victoire sur les
champs elysées en espérant revivre les
beaux jours de 98 nous irons aussi au
brésil où la presse rêve d'une revanche
samedi prochain
les soldes d'été ont démarré doucement
dans 70 départements beaucoup de monde
mais pas de raz-de-marée dans les
magasins les rabais vont durer quatre à
six semaines
les préfectures débordés par l'affluence
des familles sans papiers ayant des
enfants scolarisés à deux jours de la
fin du sursis beaucoup espèrent être
régularisés nicolas sarkozy a décidé de
nommer un médiateur au proche orient
l'armée israélienne a lancé son
offensive dans la bande de gaza pour
tenter de récupérer le soldat enlevé
dimanche
cette intervention a fait passer au
second plan la reconnaissance implicite
de l'état hébreu par le hamas enfin
l'histoire en marche dans le monde arabe
après parraine oman et le qatar les
femmes participent à leur première
élection générale au koweït comme
électrices et comme candidate alors que
la france savoure l'euphorie de la coupe
du monde nous allons donc d'abord en
belgique pour commencer ce journal il
restait un mince espoir il s'est évanoui
à quelques heures d'intervalle les
autorités ont retrouvé les corps sans
vie des deux fillettes disparues depuis
deux semaines et demie des corps caché
près d'une voie ferrée dans un quartier
populaire de liège yann fronty emmanuel
maurel
les deux corps ont été retrouvés à
quelques mètres l'un de l'autre il
reposait au bord de cette voie ferrée
enfoui dans un collecteur d'eaux usées
l'endroit très difficile d'accès a dû
être dégagé à l'aide d'engins lourds
après plus de deux semaines de fouilles
et de recherches ininterrompues
tous les espoirs sont effondrées ce
matin malheureusement ces espoirs sont
aujourd'hui ruinée par la découverte des
enfants décédés
dois-je dire assassiné il est clair que
la recherche du ou des auteurs est
devenue la priorité les corps de
nathalie et de stacy ont été découverts
à 200 mètres à peine du lieu d'où elles
ont disparu
c'était le 10 juin dernier dans ce café
au coeur d'un quartier en fête
selon les premières constatations elles
n'ont pas été séquestré les deux
fillettes auraient été assassinés le
soir de leur disparition
ont elles subi des violences sexuelles
une autopsie est en cours les résultats
devraient être publiés demain
l'enquète elle continue abdellah études
restent le principal suspect déjà
condamné pour viol sur mineure il a été
arrêté et incarcéré
il nie toute implication
oui beaucoup de questions subsistent
pourquoi at il disparu le soir du drame
alors qu'il était présent sur les lieux
pourquoi s'est il alors raser la tête
ces réponses n'ont pas convaincu la
justice
les enquêteurs eux sont à la recherche
d'indicés d'éventuelles traces adn sur
les deux corps retrouvés aujourd'hui en
direct de liège on retrouve zine dine
boudaoud bonsoir cindy l'on imagine la
consternation d'autant que le
traumatisme de la sphère du trou n'est
pas si loin oui davies la belgique toute
entière est bouleversée sous le choc des
programmes de télévision même été
interrompue laissant la place à des
éditions spéciales
les liégeois sont particulièrement
touchés bouleversés par l'assassinât des
deux fillettes
il faut dire que le pays tout entier
rattrapé par un cauchemar vieux de 11
ans en juin 1995 ici même à liège deux
fillettes
julie et mélissa avait été enlevée
violée par marc dutroux qui les a
laissées mourir de faim onze ans plus
tard l'enlèvement et l'assassinât de
nathalie et stacy replongé la belgique
dans l'horreur les affaires sont
évidemment distinctes pour autant la
police et la justice ont déjà pris les
devants cet après midi au cours d'une
conférence de presse le procureur
général a répété répété que tous les
moyens avaient été mobilisés pour
retrouver vivantes les deux fillettes
l'institution les institutions ans
j'allais dire ont été ébranlés dans
leurs fondements par les défaillances
révélées par l' affaire dutroux cet
après midi le premier ministre a fait
part dans un message sans sentiment de
chagrin d'aversion mais aussi
d'impuissance merci zine dine
on en vient maintenant à la coupe du
monde et ce lendemain de victoire pour
la france est un frisson qui a parcouru
le pays hier sur place en allemagne
l'équipe s'est donnée un peu de bon
temps envoyés spéciaux manuel tissier
vincent bouffartigue
moins de 24 heures après la liesse
l'espagne est déjà un souvenir
les bleus ont rechaussé les crampons ce
soir et comme raymond domenech
ils n'ont pas savouré longtemps la
victoire
deux minutes parce qu'après j'avais en
tête braz et ça m'est venu immédiatement
la petite musique du brésil fait
basculer laventure dans une autre
dimension en famille aujourd'hui les
joueurs et leurs épouses était d'humeur
badine
mais pour la tranquillité il faudra
repasser
aujourd'hui le château était gentiment
assiégé par des supporters chahuteurs
est confiant qu'il fallait pour les
libérer la technique je pense que là les
vieira thuram
ça va ça va continuer je pense qu'ils
vont monter en puissance au niveau
physique et ça va allez les bleus quoi
qu'il arrive samedi en quart de finale
l'équipe de france a déjà rempli son
contrat à ayrton paris ou en oeuvre sa
cote d'amour est remontée en flèche
domenech se fixe désormais une mission
de service public
les français attendent vraiment quelque
chose de cette équipe et son sens ils
sont pleins d'espoir ils ont envie aussi
d'exprimer une joie de sortir d'une
espèce de morosité qui a envahi tout le
monde
et et le football permet ça c'est un peu
aussi notre notre fonction le premier
col espagnol franchi avec brio les
tricolores s'attaque samedi à l'everest
brésilien et l'ascension ne leur fait
même pas peur
on va y revenir dans un instant mais
d'abord pour le plaisir on revient sur
cette victoire 3-1 à hyères ce que la
presse allemande avait surnommés les
papilles ont donc dominé la jeune garde
espagnole et au delà du jeu c'est aussi
l'état d'esprit de cette équipe qui a
séduit christophe du chien lui qui en a
déjà beaucoup entendu là il n'en croyait
pas ses oreilles
déjà ce bruit venu d'espagne ou des
ibériques malveillants voulait l'envoyer
au plus vite à la maison de retraite au
terminus des footballeurs et puis
surtout venue des tribunes
ces six places espagnoles pendant la
marseillaise
un peu plus tard au motif que siffler
n'ai pas joué c'est zizou en personne
qui leur couperait le sifflet avec
l'énergie l'ambition de leur belle
jeunesse les espagnols comptent ouvrir
le score à la demi-heure de jeu parce
que lilian thuram un instant marche à
côté de ces chaussures et accessoirement
sur la cheville d'un espagnol penalty
accordé par l'arbitré et transformé par
david villa l'espagne mène 1-0 le début
du fol espoir ibérique et en même temps
le commencement de la fin il nous avait
semblé lors du premier tour que les
français souvent avait égaré leur
football mais hier soir il avait
retrouvé leurs esprits et une harmonie
presque parfaite entre générations juste
avant la mi temps avec ses jambes de 23
ans ribéry égalise comme un seul homme
et continue sa course comme un sprinteur
il faudra les copains sur le bord de la
touche pour l'arrêter
avec la patience de l'artisan la
maîtrise de ses nerfs et une belle
intelligence de jeu l'équipe de france
doit prendre l'aventage à moins de dix
minutes de la fin
coup-franc zidane coup tête de vieira
détournée par un espagnol au fond de ses
filets
alors une montagne blanche se forme
composée de jeunes et de moins jeunes de
débutants et de centenaires en sélection
c'est la pyramide des âges on pourrait
disserter sans fin sur le sexe des anges
et l'âge des joueurs surtout qu'en dise
où 34 ans termine le match en beauté
j'aurai mon mot à dire moi aussi quand
sur les personnes qui ont parlé sur nous
mais là je me concentre sur ma
compétition et et puis voilà on a on
avec woody est plus tout le tout les
autres n'en vit vraiment de continuer
dans cette compétition dont combien se
reposer ce match qui sera pas facile
mais mais on a quelque chose à enfin ces
derniers temps sur le terrain les bleus
avaient perdu le goût du rire mais la
victoire contre l'espagne à changer tout
ça et on lisait hier soir sur les
visages comme un bonheur d'enfants et si
l'acquis l'équipe a retrouvé son jeu et
bien la france a retrouvé ses héros des
cours d'immeuble aux écrans géants
installés dans les stades voyons comment
ce match a été vécue images rassembler
et commenté par christelle bertrand
assis devant la télé
des milliers de spectateurs ont
transformé le stade charléty en salon à
ciel ouvert mais des annonces du penalty
on se lève comme si ça pouvait aider le
gardien français
1 0 pour l'espagne la faute à un seul
homme
au même moment à toulouse françaises et
espagnoles partagent un repas convivial
quand soudain l'ambiance devient
musicale et paquin
à l'égalisation française
c'est le délire à charléty
plus mesuré mais tout aussi intense la
joie des limougeauds reason dans tout le
centre ville
et on remet ça comme en 98 12 fois tous
à faire le petit rappel
la bayard seul terrain d'entente dans ce
restaurant parisien
les espagnols répondants français qui
prennent le dessus après le coup de
patte de vieira
on a pris un ascendant psychologique
important l'hystérie collective
tricolore s'est entendu jusqu'à berlin
les supporters français maquiller pour
mieux se reconnaître se sont donné
rendez vous au centre ville ils
partagent une émotion commune
luan chez eux à 1500 kilomètres de là a
nantes la foulée moins nombreuses mais
les supporters sont tout aussi serrée
angoisse expression alors il ne reste
plus que la prière aux espagnols mes
idoles exhorte plutôt les vues des
français le dernier but déchaîne les
passions et partout la joie à la fin du
match marque le début d'une liesse
populaire inédite pour une simple
qualification en quarts de finale
on a du mal à imaginer ce qui pourrait
se passer si la france bat le brésil
alors direct de la scène en allemagne on
retrouve manuel tissier bonsoir manuel
est ce qu'il y a aussi un petit goût de
revanche quand même pour cette équipe
qui a été très critiqué en tout cas
raymond domenech que nous que nous avons
vu aujourd'hui en conférence de presse
avaient une revanche
modeste n'a pas rajouté sur le thème du
jeu vous l'avait bien dit mais c'est
vrai que les joueurs d'abord comblée par
la victoire sont aussi ravis de faire
taire les critiques par cette très belle
victoire
c'est le cas notamment de patrick vieira
magnifique hier et nouveau buteur déjà
deux fois buteur dans cette coupe du
monde mais surtout de zinedine zidane
zidane interrogé hier par luis fernandez
chez nos confrères de rmcinfo et bien
disait à son ancien coach de cannes
qu'il était blessé
très touché par les critiques qui
avaient été émises sur ses performances
mais aussi par l'évocation de son âge de
ses 34 ans et zidane a prouvé hier comme
thuram comme barthez qu'il pouvait
encore devenir champion du monde une
seconde fois et on a vu hier qu'il y
avait de la joie dans cette équipe alors
qu on insistait surtout sur les tensions
avant on a parlé ici-même de tensions
voire de morale morosité chez les bleus
mais tout cela était un petit peu
balayée par les images d'hier de joie
notamment de ceux franck ribéry courant
sur ses camarades
c'est vrai que les joueurs n'avaient
pour l'instant montré aucun signe
extérieur de bonheur c'est le cas
aujourd'hui et la victoire d'hier
devrait effacer bien des tensions et
bien des frustrations donc les sourires
seront peut être au rendez vous avec la
victoire merci manuel l'espace d'une
soirée en tout cas la france a retrouvé
le souvenir de 1998 d'ailleurs il y
avait dix mille personnes déjà sur les
champs-elysées hier soir à paris et ce
matin le match était sur toutes les
lèvres
arnaud boutet lionel langlade avec sa
masse ou là au coup de sifflet final ils
ont envahi les lieux et imposer leur
nouveau refrain qui ne saute pas n'est
pas français
dans ce patriotisme joyeux certains
veulent tourner une page
c'est fou la france relie la france lui
la france est l'éternel
sur les champs elysées la france qui
gagne à retrouver son maître de 1998 dix
mille supporters dans cet ensemble
le bonheur même à l'elysée il flotte un
air de fête des chauffeurs aux ministres
tous revivre l'exploit sportif et
dominique de villepin fixe le nouveau
cap qu'il faut aller plus loin du
bonheur que du bluff
le magnifique française
le gouvernement laisse entendre que le
chômage va baisser et michèle alliot
marie ne cache ni son enthousiasme ni sa
nouvelle référence dans un certain
nombre de cas c'est la même volonté
d'agir et de réussir qui peut permettre
d'avancer mais je crois finalement que
l'équipe de france elle ressemble à la
france et la gauche applaudit elle aussi
l'équipe française avait l'expérience et
en même temps la niaque la ligne à pour
gagner l'avenir pour l'emporter la gnac
pour marquer des buts
sur le parvis de la défense les employés
constate les premiers changements ce
matin dans le métro je sais pas ce que
c'est moi qui avais content je crois que
les gens étaient plus souriant l'équipe
de france n'est pas à vendre mais sa
valeur ne cesse de grimper petit parole
d'expert de france était une valeur
cotée en bourse
un peu plus tôt maintenant c'est trop
tard la victoire peut-elle relancer
l'économie pourquoi pas
je pense que le match contre l'espagne
ou même si mon encontre de base il peut
lancer le moral des ménages et relancer
l'économie c'est sûr donc si on va au
bout pour s'extasier sur le fond des
problèmes absolument pas non absolument
pas
mais disons que ça peut en cacher un
certain contre la grisaille et le
pessimisme la france trouve l'éclaircie
quelques couleurs avant la prochaine
étape c'est déjà ça de gagné l'espagne
était favorite la france a brisé son
rêve tout à l'heure les joueurs sont
rentrés à la maison avec un tout petit
accueil à l'aéroport une cinquantaine de
supporters seulement avaient fait le
déplacement
l'équipe ne s'est pas attardé à ce matin
la presse invoque la fatalité et rend
hommage à zidane sur place à madrid
christian hottin thierry breton fracassé
déçu le rêve devenu cauchemar
ce matin la presse madrilène des chances
l'espagne s'est réveillé avec la gueule
de bois
l'ampleur de la défaite a mis ko les
supporteurs de l'équipe en rouge c'est
une déception par rapport aux illusions
qu'on avait sur le mondial il faut tirer
notre chapeau français pourtant tout
avait bien commencé place colonnes dans
une ambiance survoltée
avec le premier but les 20000 supporters
se déchaîne l'espagne se voit déjà en
quarts de finale
malgré l'égalisation de la france on
veut encore y croire à la mi temps on va
gagner c'est sûr après des occasions
manquées
l'espagne voit ses illusions s'envoler
et c'est zinédine zidane qui porte
l'estocade finale
sous les yeux du prince felipe zidane
que la presse espagnole voulait envoyer
à la retraite dès hier soir
aujourd'hui les commentateurs sportifs
se défend d'avoir voulu blesser la star
du football
les journalistes nous avons énormément
de respect parce que zidane a fui en
espagne est ce qu'il a apporté au
football
moi j'ai la conviction que zidane
peut-on encore faire de grands matches
comme il l'a démontré hier contre
l'espagne seule consolation pour les
espagnols ils pourront voir jouer
l'ancienne star du real madrid zinédine
zidane samedi soir face au brésil
oui une affiche magnifique c'est devenu
un classique de la coupe du monde avec
pour les brésiliens
un petit goût de revanche après la
finale perdue de 1998 aaron temps dit
abdel zoud ya quelques jongles histoire
de faire travailler les jambes quand la
tête est ailleurs
cet après midi sur leur terrain
d'entraînement en allemagne les
brésiliens pensait déjà au match de
samedi face à la france
je souhaite donc un gros gros match et
qui espère le brésil donne mais c'est un
ami comme pour les autres brésiliens qui
jouent à madrid d'ailleurs moi je suis
fier d'avoir joué à ses côtés
c'est un grand joueur quelqu'un de bien
j'espère qu'il va terminer brillamment
sa carrière sans nous marquer un but
mais je souhaite bonne chance à zidane
des artistes du ballon rond qui
jusqu'ici ont assuré le minimum syndical
quatre matches quatre victoires le
dernier face au ghana sont jamais
vraiment brillé des champions du monde
qui ont toutefois retrouvé ronaldo dans
son meilleur rôle celui de buteur
trois buts en quatre matches et le voilà
seul meilleur finisseur de l'histoire de
la coupe du monde
oubliez les kilos en trop le brésilien
tient sa revanche
dans ma vie le mot le plus important ces
patients dans les moments difficiles
comme dans les bonnes périodes j'ai
toujours été patients le brésil et
ronaldo qui ont encore la france au
travers de la gorge
quatre-vingt dix-huit bien sur les deux
buts de zidane et la coupe du monde qui
va avec
ce soir de juillet il n'y avait pas
beaucoup de samba dans le coeur des
brésiliens
tout comme en 1986 dans les tribunes de
guadalajara au mexique
au bout d'une terrible séance de penalty
fernandez offre une demi-finale à la
bande à platini est mal
platini qui remercie fernandez côté
dramatique pour nous de france moi la
première coupe de monde c'est exactement
86e souviens c'est ma cela c'était
terrible pour nous des brésiliens
revanchards qui savent que pour
accrocher une sixième étoile à leur
maillot
un sixième titre mondial il leur faudra
battre samedi la bande à zidane
le reste de l'actualité avec d'abord les
intempéries
sachez qu'une alerte aux orages de
niveau 3 sur une échelle de 4 a été
lancée par météo france dans cinq
départements de la région rhône alpes et
sur la haute loire
attention donc si vous habitez la région
car le vent la pluie et la grêle peuvent
être violents ce soir et cette nuit hier
et grêlons de la taille de balles de
tennis parfois ont causé de nombreux
dégâts
comme ici à une soixantaine de
kilomètres de lyon l'alertent en tout
cas est en vigueur jusqu'au milieu de la
nuit
le démarrage des soldes d'été c'est
parti pour quatre à six semaines de
bonnes affaires dans 70 départements
mais cette journée a confirmé que ces
périodes de rabais ne font plus autant
recette christelle martin nathalie
gallet 8h ce matin c'est la revue et des
accros aux bonnes affaires
tout sur apporté très sympa avec des
petits talons
là j'ai pris à quelques dit c'est bon
goût tout ça oui oui oui combien je
formule des soldes d'été qui démarrent
fort sur les prix cette année jusqu'à
70% de ristournes des premiers jours ça
vaut vraiment le coup
il ya des grosses réductions dès le
début préfère fermer seul parce qu'on y
gagne quoi 50% c'est tout il ya que le
50% qui motive 559 euros c'est un peu
plus que ce que dépensent chaque ménage
français en moyenne comptait 105 euros
par foyer pendant les soldes
même si certaines ne dépasse largement
ce budget j'ai un budget de 30 ans
d'euros pour la journée non pour les
soldes en général mais sanctionnent pas
partir aujourd'hui
pour l'ensemble des sols ni par
l'ensemble mais après on verra par la
suite
côté commerçants on espère rattraper les
mauvaises ventes de ces derniers mois et
faire du chiffre sol de bp vont nous
permet de réaliser près de 12 à 13% du
chiffre d'affaires de l'année
on attend comme d'habitude beaucoup de
monde a été quand même assez dur et par
rapport au temps par rapport aux
tendances mais sinon bon on espère comme
tout le monde que le premier jour de
soldes ça va être efficace pour nous
bilan de cette première journée un
démarrage en douceur mais il reste entre
quatre et six semaines pour se rattraper
économie en bref toujours le coprésident
de eads noël forgeard dans le groupe
traverse une crise industrielle sans
précédent était entendue aujourd'hui par
la commission des finances de
l'assemblée nationale
il a exclu de démissionner selon les
députés présents noël forgeard est mise
en cause pour avoir vendu un gros paquet
d'actions avant l'annoncé des
difficultés de l'a380 qui ont fait
plonger le titre
il a répété qu'il n'était pas au courant
à cette période là rappelons qu'une
enquête de l'autorité des marchés
financiers est en cours
en bref encore des remous à paris match
pour la première fois de son histoire la
rédaction de l'hebdomadaire a voté pour
une journée de grève afin de protester
contre l'éviction du directeur de la
rédaction alain genestar pour des
raisons politiques fin de citation la
rue et dans les préfectures des familles
sans papiers ayant des enfants
scolarisés on a déjà évoqué ce dossier
ici même le sursis accordé à ces
familles par le ministère de l'intérieur
s'achève dans deux jours nicolas sarkozy
a indiqué qu'il y aurait des
régularisations mais seulement au cas
par cas
d'où cette affluence depuis hier matin
orolia guillemin hervé pozzo ils sont
assez derrière ces barrières depuis des
heures quand le centre de réception des
étrangers ouvre ses portes
les centaines de sans papiers arrivés
parfois en pleine nuit pour être les
premiers à demander leur régularisation
que sa première fille sophie nouvelles
voies et les enfants scolarisés leur
part doivent avoir les produits alors
c'est pourtant je suis là depuis hier
hier j'étais la 9e aujourd'hui je me
suis est hélas un fake heures 35 avec ce
site leur c'est une nouvelle vie pour
qu'ils commencent la circulaire dont
tous parlent date du 13 juin dernier
elle élargit ponctuellement les
conditions de régularisation aux parents
d'au moins un enfant scolarisé en france
au delà de la durée passée sur le
territoire sont notamment prises en
compte l'attitude des parents quant à
l'éducation des enfants et la volonté
d'intégration les instructions de la
circulaire sont un réexamen des
situations au cas par cas
il n'y a donc pas d'objectif chiffré il
y a un objectif de sortir de la
précarité les familles qui ont des
enfants scolarisés mais certains
craignent toujours que la fin de l'année
scolaire soit l'occasion d'expulsion la
mairie du 20e arrondissement de paris a
donc organisé une journée de parrainage
pour soutenir 70 familles sans papiers
les cachets si c'est si à la police
qu'il est si qui débarque 4 heures du
matin ils vont être mère au téléphone
on a fait de la montée des jantes devant
les quatre centres d'accueil des
étrangers l'attend continuent pour
l'heure 500 familles ont obtenu leur
examen de leur situation
les autres ont deux mois pour en faire
la demande et on apprend que c'est
l'avocat arno klarsfeld qui vient d'être
nommé médiateur par nicolas sarkozy pour
harmoniser les décisions préfectorales
de régularisation sur le sujet nicolas
sarkozy qui présentait aujourd'hui son
projet de loi sur la prévention de la
délinquance ond conseil des ministres il
s'agit vous le savez de donner plus de
pouvoirs au maire et aussi de durcir les
peines et les procédures contre les
mineurs délinquants
on va s'arrêter en détail sur ce dernier
point d'abord les explications sur ce
projet audrey goutard la répression et
maintenant la prévention le projet
entend s'attaquer aux grands domaines de
la délinquance aux violences conjugales
aux infractions sexuelles à la lutte
contre la drogue
il propose également un renforcement
accru des pouvoirs du maire les élus des
villes de plus de 10 mille habitants
pourront exiger la mise sous tutelle des
allocations familiales lorsque les
parents seront jugés défaillants mais là
ce central du projet et le durcissement
de la lutte contre la délinquance des
mineurs
nicolas sarkozy l'a encore souligné hier
à l'assemblée il veut supprimer l'excusé
de minorité à mineurs récidivistes entre
16 et 18 ans l'excusé de minorité ne
doit plus être appliqué systématiquement
quand on est récidiviste et qu'on ne
veut pas comprendre la société doit
appliquer une sanction plus sévère sans
le réformer en profondeur le projet
s'attaque aux traitements actuels des
mineurs délinquants
il propose notamment leur placement en
internat dès l'âge de 10 ans des travaux
d'intérêt général dès 13 ans ainsi
qu'une justice immédiate plus sévère
avec une présentation rapide devant un
magistrat et un jugement dans la foulée
le gouvernement a pourtant dû faire
machine arrière par rapport à son projet
initial
il a retiré du texte proposé par le
ministère de l'intérieur le dépistage
précoce des troubles du comportement
chez l'enfant
mais la mesure n'a pas pour autant
disparu elle sera présentée par le
ministère de la famille
pour bien comprendre le problème posé
par cette délinquance des mineurs en
augmentation depuis des années nous
avons décidé de partager au quotidien la
vie d'un tribunal pour enfants
à béthune les magistrats avoir
régulièrement arriver les mêmes
adolescents et se sentent parfois
impuissant c'est le dossier de cette
édition il est signé à new burel
catherine juste qu elle rappelle à l
ouïe fou tu comprennes sani les
convocations dans le bureau du juge des
enfants il connaît cela fait plus de
cinq ans qu'il est dans la violence
comme il dit ils fument du cannabis
il boit et puis ils cassent permanence à
17 ans il a été condamné pour agression
sexuelle
le tribunal l'a soumis à des obligations
qu'il n'a pas su défier l'enjeu aussi
l'enjeu c'est effectivement la prison ça
se passe comment à la maison en ce
moment pourquoi c'est quoi ton projet
par rapport à ta santé par rapport à son
avenir
comment alors la bible la télé dans la
violence mais c'est pas une raison pour
le pour faire pareil au tribunal de
béthune ce matin là il ya du monde dans
les couloirs devant les bureaux des
juges des enfants
il ya aussi des habitués kevin 16 ans il
vient cette fois pour un vol de cd et de
chocolat la dernière fois ils avaient
vandalisé un bureau de tabac
à côté de lui jérôme il a volé une moto
il a déjà été placé trois fois dans des
centres fermés
la peur ou pas des sanctions bond 23
il faut donc par exemple si on te disait
il faut que tu ailles en prison tu
penses que ça ferait avancer les choses
ou pas maintenant et je crée mon temps
qui passe au tribunal c'est plus un
événement si certains jeunes issus du
quotidien si je le savais quelle réponse
apporter à ces jeunes récidivistes
selon la loi la prison doit rester le
dernier recours
retour à l'audience de samedi marche je
pense qu'il faut que tu comprennes que
quand il ya une décision qui est prise
elle doit s'appliquer à un moment donné
aujourd'hui tu va repartir avec l'escort
on va là pied et tu vas dormir en prison
est mort sept lui permet de sortir
s'effondre un petit peu quinze jours de
détention pour le jeune garçon alors
après cinq ans de mesures éducatives et
chaque ou pas ce qui l'a amené là c'est
tout un parcours personnel effectivement
vous l'avez entendu familial éducatif on
pourrait se poser la question de l'échec
de l'éducatif moi je n'irai pas jusqu'à
dire que c'est un échec puisque on a vu
quand même un mineur qui réagissait à
skis lui ce qui lui était dit c'est la
quatrième fois dans l'année que le juge
des enfants prend cette décision pour
des mineurs à béthune il y avait mille
six cents à faire l'année dernière un
chiffre stable
850 comparution au tribunal ou devant le
juge et 750 alternative aux poursuites
selon le procureur on ne peut pas
généraliser les mineurs récidivistes se
suivent mais ne se ressemblent pas il ya
des mineurs de 16 ans qui sont encore
marqués par des traits infantile par des
comportements qui sont pas matures et
d'autres qui ont quand même beaucoup
plus proche des traits de personnalité
beaucoup plus proche de la majorité au
pas avoir de vue trop absolue et à
frontières des 18 ans c'est une
frontière qui est parfois est fixée par
le code mais qui est parfois un peu
difficile à gérer
sami lui à 18 ans aujourd'hui il va
encore être suivi à sa sortie de prison
pour éviter qu'il ne récidive justice en
bref avec le procès de david hotyat
c'est l'heure des réquisitions l'avocat
général a demandé l'arrêt
plusieurs à perpétuité avec une peine de
sûreté de 22 ans
david hotyat est accusée vous le savez
de l'assassinât des cinq membres de la
famille flactif au grand bornand il ya
trois ans le verdict sera rendu vendredi
et puis à marrakech on en parlait hier
le directeur de théâtre français jacques
henri soumère a été blanchi de
l'accusation d'incitation d'un mineur à
la prostitution
il a en revanche été condamné à quatre
mois de prison avec sursis pour
homosexualité elle constitue un délit au
maroc
jacques henri soumère a indiqué qu'il
souhaitait faire appel au proche orient
l'armée israélienne a lancé son
offensive dans la bande de gaza pour
tenter de récupérer le soldat enlevé
dimanche elle à bombarder des ponts des
routes est une centrale électrique pour
essayer de cerner les ravisseurs
charles enderlin tana bourny en pleine
nuit l'aviation israélienne a bombardé
le principal transformateur et la petite
centrale électrique de gaza
résultat sept cent mille palestiniens
n'ont plus d'électricité
ce boucher a bien un générateur mais
très peu de carburant pour le faire
fonctionner je me dépêche de vendre la
viande qu'il me reste terme et
réfrigérateurs vont s'arrêter après je
vais rentrer chez moi
les hélicoptères ont également détruit
trois ponts coupant ainsi les principaux
axes de circulation entre le nord et le
sud de gaza
les véhicules ne peuvent plus passer
peu de rapport l'armée israélienne
continuent de masser des plaintes
les chefs militaires sont persuadés que
gilad shalit le soldat enlevé dimanche
dernier et ses ravisseurs se trouve
toujours dans le secteur
son père noam a lancé un appel au
gouvernement israélien
nous demandons qu'il n'y ait pas
d'autres victimes
des soldats et des civils innocents des
deux côtés israélien et palestinien ehud
olmert le premier ministre a rejeté une
proposition du gouvernement palestinien
de procéder à un échange de prisonniers
la situation se détériore d'heure en
heure
le groupe qui détient le soldat a
également enlevé un jeune colon en
cisjordanie qu il menace de tuer si
israël poursuit ses opérations
l'émancipation féminine progresse à
petits pas au proche orient après
barennes oman et le qatar les femmes
participent à leur première élection
générale au koweït comme électrices et
également comme candidate envoyés
spéciaux yasmina farber philippe
chasselas les brumisateurs
rafraîchissent la transfère 37° à la
nuit tombée le débat politique peut
commencer
les premières femmes se retrouvent pour
le meeting d'alxa al-rachid la
journaliste se présente à ces élections
législatives un moment d'histoire
la première fois qu'une femme participe
à un vote comme électrices et comme
candidate
tous les regards sont tournés vers nous
plaît la femme qu etienne est la clé de
ces élections
dans le public un curieux mélange de
femmes voilées et d'autres figures
modernes de la société koweïtienne sous
le chapiteau des hommes aussi
mais instinctivement on ne se mélange
pas tout et le blanc n'oubliez pas tous
ceux qui ont voté contre le droit de
vote des femmes
c'est le message des châles rachid
n'écoutez pas les amis les maris les
frères les fils allait à tous les
meetings l'horreur dans ce quartier très
conservateur la candidature d'un chien
al-rachid ne plaît pas du tout une femme
au pouvoir relèverait du non sens adel
al saraawi est un député salafistes la
tendance radicale de l'islam au
parlement il s'est opposé au vote des
femmes
la charia la loi islamique est clair où
la femme a le droit d'être électrices
mais la loi interdit à une femme d'être
candidate en ouvrant les portes du
parlement à des femmes
le koweït devient la monarchie du golfe
la plus progressiste roula dachti
brillant économiste aura milité 20 ans
je sentais qu'on avait aucun droit qu'on
était des numéros ça nous a donné de
l'énergie de la motivation il fallait
qu'on devienne des citoyennes à part
entière des femmes sous le charme et des
hommes qui félicite la candidate l'image
symbole d'une nouvelle société
ironie de ce vote des électrices 158
plus que les électeurs et les 32
candidates ont malgré tout peu de
chances de l'emporter
face à des hommes politiques richissime
qui achètent les voix a plu 2002
en france pas de teknival sur
l'aérodrome de vannes c'est du moins ce
qu'a décidé la justice aujourd'hui
l'arrêté de réquisition du terrain
n'était pas conforme selon le juge près
de 40000 personnes s'était pourtant
donné rendez-vous ce week-end pour l'une
des plus importantes rêve de l'année les
pouvoirs publics vont tenter de trouver
un nouveau lieu pour éviter un
rassemblement sauvage car les
participants semblent bien décidés à
assurer son déroulement de la danse pour
terminer avec cette première à l'opéra
garnier à paris la dame aux camélias
version ballet le roman d'alexandre
dumas fils a été adapté sur des musiques
de chopin il sera désormais joué
régulièrement sophie jouve didier da
comme au siècle dernier à l'heure de sa
gloire en coulisses elle se prépare la
dame aux camélias
courtisane connu dans le monde entier
elle fit tourner la tête du tout paris
et battre le coeur de ses adorateurs
quand on sait qu'elle habitait près de
la madeleine bâ loin qu'elle passait ses
soirées l'opéra parce que là d'orissa
c'est sûr que c'est là qu'il fallait
donner ce ballet
évidemment dans ce paris du 19ème siècle
une femme de vie légère même adulé ne
peut faire sa place dans la société
bourgeoise pour cette histoire d'amour
impossible de marguerite gautier avec
son bel armand 2h30 de balle est très
europe différente
un marathon pour une étoile
peut pas se douter je crois quand on
vend la salle de ce qui se passe dans
les coulisses on et 150 à l'heure et
j'arrive en scène et je suis très zen et
très calme alors qu'en coulisse jeu
court dans tous les sens
décors somptueux comme dans l'hôtel
particulier de marguerite gautier
musique fiévreuse de chopin mort de la
tuberculose comme elle
le chorégraphe américain john mayer
évoque un destin qui a défié le temps ce
peace in which c'est une histoire à
laquelle je crois qu'on pratique elle
est malade de la tuberculose y switcher
final dont on souffre moins aujourd'hui
sur match n'a pas détruit mais ce
pourrait être du sida quelque chose
d'actuel
avec une régie du pont et un manuel
legris romantique à souhait un siècle et
demi après sa mort douloureuse
la dame aux camélias débute à paris une
carrière de danseuse fin de ce journal
merci de l'avoir suivi tout de suite la
météo patrice drevet 20h55 une fiction
je hais les parents avec daniel prévost
à demain